interesting it wasn't it i thought i
loved danger mouse
but i thought it was what prompted that
decision to try something new this time
just wanting something different yeah
like we know rick and we know we're
gonna get a very high quality producer
and rick and a good friend yeah you know
he's great at what he does obviously
but we wanted to
get uncomfortable
and explore something different within
ourselves
and we also wanted to add an element
that we hadn't before and not not in a
forced way or a contrived way but let's
let's get our chemistries in the same
pot and see what happens
and it worked you know we rolled the
dice it was a risk we didn't know him
that well
we didn't want to sound like a danger
mouse record we wanted to sound like us
but i think what we got was a great mix
and he turned out to be as caring
and
attentive and focused and just
when he gets something started it's not
half-assed or it's not he's not phoning
it in he got there early and he left
late like kobe bryant like
he wanted it to be
better than everybody else
he wasn't gonna settle for well this is
okay
anything that i would sing to him that
he felt was just okay he would be like
no next
give me give it to me again find
something else
and i'll like okay i'll go home and
write he's like no right now start
singing ideas were you surprised by that
that yeah yeah yeah yeah but but also
impressed yeah like it takes a courage
and a intelligence to tell somebody
who's been doing something for 30 years
that's not quite good enough it's okay
but we're looking for better than that
what was your reaction to that uh a
little bit of frustration but also it's
coming from a positive place like it's
not his arrogance or
being a control freak he just wants it
to be
the best
so it's good the uh dark necessities
doing amazing i mean it's your 25th
song to chart in the top 10 which is
which is pretty amazing
thanks for the info did you know you
didn't know that yeah congratulations i
mean does it come effortlessly at this
point or do you still concentrate and
think about writing the hit
never thought about writing a hit in my
life
um and it's never effortless it we
worked so hard for so long day in day
out some days it just doesn't happen you
try so hard i heard that music
before i wrote lyrics and melody to it
and fell in love with it
and that one i kind of had my a general
sense of what i was going to do from the
first time i heard it it was like you
see somebody you fall in love you know
how you're gonna kiss that person i
heard that song i was like i think i
know what i'm gonna do on this i have my
part it just came to me
other songs you fall in love with but
you're like
i don't know where i fit in like what do
you even do in this music it just
doesn't make sense
and it takes
effort after effort until you finally
solve the mystery you crack the code and
you're like yes this rhythm this
whatever works
and brian was super helpful in helping
me get there
speaking of doing what works i mean when
you've been at something for 32
over 30 years 32 years i think it is um
you ever look back on some of the things
you've done and just think what was i
thinking then whether it's fashion
whether it's a move you made whether
it's a song
moves no because even the most
ridiculous moves
i'm all for them sometimes the more
absurd and embarrassing the better
fashion i've had a couple of moments
where i do question my sanity
late 80s that weird in between like 80s
was colorful and wild and you know
decadent and
wonderful fashion wise like feathers and
everything goes but towards the end of
the 80s there was that little lost in
space time where you didn't quite know
how to express yourself fashion wise and
i've seen some photo shoots and i was
like whoa
i had a woman's hair band in my long
hair thinking that that would be somehow
the right look and it just looks silly
song wise
i don't even mind writing a bad song or
a silly song or a song that i don't want
to play today
it made sense at that moment if it's a
song and we worked on it i have love for
it
so very little regret about songs even
if they're not good or there's something
i would never want to play together i
remember why we wrote it when we wrote
it it had a purpose
yeah what about your relationship with
music i mean how does how does that
change i'm sure when you got into music
what you wanted to get out of music
was maybe different than what you your
relationship with music now
i couldn't even analyze it accurately
it's music still gives me one of the
best feelings
on earth when i when i hear the right
song
it's just ecstasy so i and i had that as
a kid a lot like when i got turned on
the music uh in my teens whether it was
jazz or funk or
the clash or whomever
and i heard it i was like yes let's
dance or you know let's jump around or
let's cry or you know let's make out or
whatever
that feeling is irreplaceable and i
still look for that all the time